[Music]
and you're live chairman thank you thank
you
Tara good afternoon and welcome to of
this District planning committee meeting
on Wednesday the 3rd of June 2020 my
name is councelor Bob boy and I am the
chairman of this committee this remote
meeting is held under new regulations
which came into effect on the 4th of
April in response to the coid 19
situation there are just a few
housekeeping issues to run through
including our new work in practice which
have been implemented due to the
pandemic and the etiquette for this
meeting first of all please could I ask
everyone present in this meeting to
ensure your microphone remains muted and
your video feed off when not address in
the committee this will reduce
background noise and avoid any
unintentional
disturbances this meeting will be hosted
remotely via conference software which
allows members of the public to
virtually attend the meeting whilst
being able to protect themselves and
others and observe the government's
lockdown
measures we may encounter some glitches
this afternoon so I hope that everyone
will bear with
us as we get used to this new way of
working we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being
recorded members and officers during
each item please use the chat function
of the meeting to indicate if you wish
to speak I will then invite you at the
appropriate time members are reminded
that apart from indicating you wish to
speak speak or that you have you have to
leave the meeting the chat function
should not be used for any other
purpose members the process this
afternoon will obviously be different
and for some items I may invite each
member to speak in turn therefore I
would encourage all members to keep your
contribution as clear and concise uh as
possible please when speaking and
referring to the agenda papers please
ensure you reference a page or paragraph
number could I also ensure that everyone
is directly connected to a power supply
so that nobody drops out due to short
battery
life and last if members need to leave
the meeting at any point please make
this known and use the chat function to
imply to sign function to signify that
you need to leave the
meeting May I now ask officers taking
part in the meeting to intro introduce
themselves first one I think is Mr
Johson chairman he's not on the live
meeting okay uh uh Mr Lee Matt
Lee good afternoon members and members
of public I am Matthew Lee and I am the
lead specialist for place here at molden
District
Council I've got
Michael
Michael good afternoon chair good
afternoon members of the my name is
Michael Johnson I am the lead specialist
for development management thank
you
K good afternoon everybody my name is
Devon herner and I'm a specialist in
development management at monen
Council
Tara good afternoon chairman good
afternoon members I'm Tara bird I'm the
committee Services officer for this
meeting thank you Tara is there anybody
any other officer present
uh not that I'm aware of chairman uh
thank you uh could you now please carry
out a roll call of members to confirm
who is in attendance thank you yes
chairman I members I'm going to call
your names alphabetically if you could
just um switch your camera and
microphone on and confirm that you're
present please um starting with
councelor
Bamford yes
president councilor
Bassinger yes president
Miss
Bill councelor Brian
Bill councelor Bell yes present thank
you councelor Boyce pres councelor Mrs
Chana hello yes I'm present Council
darham present thank you coun counc
Edwards councelor
Edwards yes present thank you councelor
Mrs
Fleming present
Tara
fluka
presid some somebody has put up a slide
please can I remove it this CH you're SK
sharing your screen at the
moment thank you sorry councelor Harker
present thank you councelor
herd good afternoon chairman and uh
Hall present thank you councelor
Jarvis present
Tara councelor keys
councelor
lagin present teror thank you councelor
Ma president thank
youy yeah thank you Council M he sends
it Council Moy sends it apologist please
thank you very much councelor
Morris
counc Morris you're muted
sorry need to unmute
yourself good afternoon and welcome
thank you very much councelor
nun yes here Tara thank you councelor
shaes yes here Tara thanks councelor
Sidle yes here thank you councelor skin
hi yes good afternoon
everybody
stamp yes I'm here Tara thank you thank
you councelor
stilts yes Tara I'm here thank you
councelor
Swain present thank you councelor Mrs
Thompson U present hello chairman thank
you thank you councelor Miss
White I'm here but I am in a busy office
so I won't be turning the video option
on it will just be a voicemail thank you
okay thank you very much thank you
chairman that is the attendance
done thank you Tara agenda item two
apologies for absence and I note the
councelor bell and councelor jick is
there anybody else Tara uh yes councelor
um councelor moley um and obviously
councelor Helm sorry I'm here Mr
chairman I'm here councelor Bell yeah oh
uh
um thank you so chairman I have
apologies from councilor dck councelor
hel councelor
moley thank you Tara thank you um we go
on to agenda item three minutes of the
last
meeting um the minutes of the last
meeting held on the 12th of March 2020
found on pages 9 to4 are approved as a
true and accurate record I so move if
you wish to second that motion please
turn on your video unmute mute your
microphone and state your name
now
second I seconded thank
you uh if any member wishes to raise a
matter of accuracy please use the chat
function to indicate and I will invite
you to
speak Tara can you advise if any other
members have indicated to wish to speak
uh no chairman there is no indication of
anyone wishing to speak thank you thank
you
uh now will you take the vote and um can
we do it by consensus if there is any
objection to the minutes please say so
otherwise we will assume that the
consensus is approval of the
minutes okay I'm against any assumed
consent sorry I'm against any con any
assumed thank you councelor moris u c um
Tara would you take the vote
please yes chairman you want me to go
through and read out and get everyone to
come please of course can you turn your
video off councelor
Morris members I'm gonna F go through
alabe leave you can just please can you
turn your video
off councel
bford agree thank you councelor
Bassinger agree thank you councelor Bell
agree thank you councelor boy
agree yeah counc Mrs
Chana agree thank you councelor Durham
agreed councelor
Edwards agreed councilor Mrs
Fleming agreed thank you councelor
Fluker agreed counc Harker
agreed coun
herd
agreed the
hall councelor
Hall agreed thank you councelor Jarvis
agreed thank you councelor
Lagan agreed counc
ma agreed thank you councilor Morris
abin thank
you none agreed thank you counc
C agreed thank you councelor Sidle
agreed thank you councel
skines agreed councelor
stamp and T sorry to ask what was the
date again of this one um with me sorry
sorry chairman but I think I was away
cuz my dad's dad died I think it was the
12th of March I think I was away so I I
I'll abstain please Tara of course thank
you very much councelor
stilts
agreed thank you councelor
Swain
agreed thank you councelor Mrs
Thompson agreed and Council Miss White
agreed thank you chairman and that's 24
in agreement and two
extensions thank you Tara the minutes
are there
approved councelor
be uh Miss B yeah I am here sorry
haven't got me I haven't got myology but
I'm catching up yeah oh tar did you make
a note
agree yeah I've made a note and change
that thank you
councelor thank you chair then we go on
to agenda item
five uh land west of two molden Road
burnam on
Crouch we move to agenda item five
planning application 20 stroke
0387 stroke Rees for land west of two
molden Road burnam on Crouch found on
pages 15 to 54 please note that a member
update in relation to this application
has been circulated prior to the meeting
Kevin would you like to uh present the
your report please chairman just to
interrupt um we haven't done
Declarations of Interest oh I'm agenda
item four I'm
sorry uh agenda item four Declarations
of
Interest strange that uh may I come in
chairman sorry I couldn't get the chat
up Mrs Janny yes yes uh chairman I must
declare an interest I'm also an Essex
County council member and obviously
Essex County council's being consulted
on this application as indeed it was on
the outline application regarding
highways and various other matters that
I come under the remit of Essex County
Council thank you chairman I too have
the same Declaration of Interest as a
member of Essex County Council for the
same reasons as councelor Chan has just
given thank you councelor darham Tara is
there anybody
else I didn't get that did somebody else
call yes Council sches
chairman yeah coun councelor schemes
well I'm a member of buram Town Council
which obviously gives me a direct
interest in this
non-un and uh I know one of the land
owners thank you Tara anybody else yes
please
and yeah and
burnam yeah
and your interest works for
wilon can you hear me my partner works
for John
Wilson thank
you
Tara uh chairman nobody else has um
indicated they wish to declare an
interest thank you we'll just pause
we'll just pause for a second to see if
there's anybody else Tara councelor
Bassinger B councelor Bassinger hello I
I know one of the land
owners non beun thank
you point of order please point of order
please can I ask hang on can I
ask ask who is speaking on a point of
order please in regard to any of I ask
who's speaking on a point of order
Chrissy
Morris thank you your point of order is
I'd like know if fluka has got any
pecuniary interests with any of the land
that is not that is not an admissible
point of order councilor
Morris um Tara can we then go back to um
agender item five uh yes chairman nobody
else has
indicated um chairman could we just
confirm with councelor Hall which what
her interest is please is it pecuniary
or non-pecuniary
uh
go back to councelor Hull councelor
Morris please turn your video off and
stop displaying information
be I don't know I I my partner works for
John Wilston who owns the
land well done councelor
Hall so do you know how would that be
um um counselor Hull I'm not able to
give you that advice and I don't believe
Mr quch is is
here um so your safest uh bet would be
um to leave the meeting at the voting
stage okay do do I leave the meeting all
through the runup to it or just the vot
it I I believe you can stay and and
listen to the
debate uh but it it's it is your it is
your decision not mine why wasn't
that why wasn't that our pecul interest
counc councelor Morris councelor Morris
address your questions to the the
chairman please and that isn't a
relevant question at this stage well
that a member hasn't put stuff on their
register of
interest
uh if it was relevant but I don't
believe that is relevant Sticky Wicket
this one Bob in it no it's not please
coun Morris please would you switch your
video off councelor Morris you're
disrupting this meeting please switch
your video
off uhair is councelor Beal yeah I do
know Mr Wilston non than you I think we
need to move on uh now members see as
counc Bill wasn't in the meeting to
start with councelor bill got any voting
uh uh right yes she has because the
declarate the matter under discussion
has not been started
yet chairman it's councilor Beal I have
been here from the start of the meeting
10 minutes before I just wasn't sure how
to actually be able to speak yeah no
that's that's all right counselor Bill
you're you're quite okay um uh can we
now go again to agenda item five
uh and
I've moved the agenda item five which is
the application land west of tomen
Road can I just make a declaration of
Interest councilor herd go on thank you
only that I although I can't find count
uh Mr Wilson's name in the papers uh I
do know him as his an next town C
councelor non Peary thank you councelor
herd we now move to agenda item five
Devin please make your presentation
councelor Morris please turn your video
off right well it'll be turned off for
you councelor Devon that's
fine councelor Devon oh miss miss Devon
sorry no problem B me one moment I'm
just trying to share the screen
hopefully can see that yeah thank you
chairman so this proposal is a reserve
matters application for the approval of
the appearance landscaping and scale in
relation to a retirement community which
was previously granted outline
permission in two in September
2019 as access and layout were
considered and approved under the
previous outline permission this
application so solely relates to the
appearance landscaping and scale
therefore it wouldn't be reasonable to
consider or object to the application on
the basis of the propos on the basis of
the layout the density or the overall
urbanization of the site and likewise it
would not be reasonable to object on the
impacts on the existing infrastructure
or wider Services as this was addressed
at the outline stage and is subject to
the sign section
106 so here we have the location plan
you can see molden road to the south of
the site and tinker's hole up to the
[Music]
West
this is the layout plan as I've
mentioned layout was previously agreed
at outline but this is just um for
reference purposes to show you the
different uses within the site so we
have the 10 mini communities of
Bungalows which are um largely arranged
around one another with linear
development along molden Road and then
the commercial uh Leisure facilities and
things like that are located within the
central eastern part of the site
here so this is the landscape master
plan um and Landscaping is a
consideration for this application you
can see we've got the local equipped
area of play here to the west of the
community center and some Suds features
over to the east of the site and it Al
shows you the overall planting strategy
and hard surfacing layout within the
center of the proposed mini communities
as they referred to are small areas of
landscaped open space in some cases
they'll provide areas for visitor
parking and as well spaces for
allotments if they should be taken up
seating and outdoor meeting spaces each
of the Bungalows are to be served by a
small patio area which is enclosed by
ornamental planting but it should be
noted there's no formal defined
boundaries or means of enclosure which
is considered a positive design element
of the scheme parking for the Bungalows
to the front and to the sides of them
and then you can see um parking for the
uh commercial uses are located at around
and adjacent to the
buildings the Landscaping scheme also
seeks to preserve the important existing
landscape features of the site most
notably the existing hedge RS to the
southern eastern and western boundaries
and the tree line ditch which bisects
the site on an East of West
axis there's also a native hedge Ro to
be proposed along the northern
boundary this brings us on to the design
of the proposed Bungalows there's a mix
of pitch roof flat roof and mixed FL
flat and Pitch roof sorry properties
across the site this is a one bed Mi
mixed pitch
Bungalow a flat roof one big
Bungalow and a pitch roof one big
Bungalow here we have pitched two
bedroom
Bungalow two bed mix
pitch a two bed flat
pitched a three bed mixed pitch and the
three bed um Pitch property so this
shows some illustrative in images of the
Bungalows and their Street Scenes it's
considered that the Bungalows have a
contemporary design which is combined
with traditional form and massing the
design and scale differences between the
Bungalow types offer a degree of
architectural interest with uniformity
being made maintained through the
pallette of materials and the different
roof forms also conform to the
principles the design guide by creating
a varied roof line and offering a
suitable transition into the adjacent
Countryside and I believe that they
ensure that the overall mass and scale
of the Bungalows is not domineering and
that they relate to the other buildings
proposed at the site which I'll go on to
show
you here we have the in uh Independent
Living units the floor plans and so
they'll be divided into three blocks uh
separated by twostory walkways which
helps break up the mass slightly
um sorry to interrupt but there's a lot
of banging going
on yeah I can hear that also I don't
know I don't think it's coming from my
end that
better sounds like someone's got a DIY
project going
on carry on please this application fluk
is doing
it carry on Deon please okay chairman
thank
you so the central Courtyards will be um
soft Landscapes and there solar panels
to the
roofs we have the elevations uh just for
illustrative perf showing you block one
and then there's a section of the whole
building illustrative sketch view
showing you what they will look
like and then illustrative imagery of
the independent living
blocks here we have the floor plans of
the Care Homes you can see this is a
ground floor with the external layout uh
first floor and roof
plan and it's
elevations 3D
views and some illustrative
drawings and this is the community
center elevations
and some 3D views of that one as
well this is a medical center floor
plans and elevations the medical center
largely consists of glass and full
length glazing with supports to the roof
here you've got some illustrative views
and it's been designed to be a permeable
structure so there's a relationship
between the internal parts of the
building and the public realm that was
all of the commercial uh the flat roof
commercial buildings sorry that are
proposed and the flat roof design of
each of the commercial buildings discuss
is considered to reduce the prominent
prominence of the buildings and if a
pitch roof had been proposed and it
isn't an uncommon design approach for
buildings like this it's also worth just
noting that the outline permission
limits the buildings to two stories so
if a pitch roof were to be added the
overall bulk of mass of the pro proposal
would be exacerbated and there'd be
little scope to object on that
basis this is the mixed use building so
you have the shops um takeaways Etc at
ground floor with Flats at first floor
and second
floor the building has been designed to
provide AC acoustic installation between
the ground floor uses and the
residential accommodation which should
mitigate against any noise impacts as
the condition um proposing appropriate
hours of use should also do here we have
the elevations and you probably note
that they're more traditional in style
with the Gable windows and the covered
parade to the front of the shop unit
the more traditional design is
considered to lend well to the sighting
of the shopping parade because it's kind
of within its own setting within the
site and assimilates with the setting of
the wet wet Lakes to the
east here's some illustrative drawings
of
this this plan shows the um maintenance
and site offices within the SES you have
the maintenance building site office
sales office and security security
office the maintenance building
elevations and floor plans
the same for the security
office and the site
office this is the Refuge plan so each
of the colored areas are served by a
refuge store which is um you can see the
refug store and the more
solid out they get collected by um
on-site buggies and stuff and deposited
in these waste areas to get collected by
an external party which just prevents
the need for any Refuge vehicle
entering um the estate roads and causing
any safety issues and then the design of
them are down in the bottom right hand
corner and uh plans and elevations of a
couple of The Refuge
stores here we have the proposed Street
scenes
photos uh surrounding street scene
photos more photos of the site
and some more photos again so conclude
to conclude it's considered that the
details of scale and appearance and
Landscaping submitted or acceptable and
would not not result in demonstrable
harm to the character of the area the
development complies with the
obligations agreed through the 106
agreement of the outline permission and
it would also represent a development
that's in keeping with the character of
the built form within the area and would
provide good level of living conditions
for um the future occupiers subject to
appropriate conditions the details in
relation to the public open space are
considered acceptable as is the car
parking proposals the and therefore the
details of development are considered to
Accord with the aims of the development
plan and the conditions and the
obligations imposed to the outline
permission for that reason the
application is recommended for approval
but just before we move on there's just
a few um further members updates to um
bring your attention to so the update
was circulated yesterday but since we've
had two new letters of public
representation it's not considered that
they raise any new material
considerations the matters raised relat
to design environmental impacts and the
location of the site in relation to
nearby
amenities the design has been addressed
in the committee report and part of this
presentation and the other matters were
dealt with outline uh consultation
response has also been received from ESS
County council's grow off growth officer
but it relates to the principle of
development which isn't for
consideration as part of this
application the applicant agent has
provided a response to the letter um to
that effect
also and I've also proposed a slight
amendment to condition 10 just in
relation to permitted development rights
to prevent Gates walls fencing or hard
standing being erected under permitted
development in the future and then
condition 19 is a new condition that
just requires um one master anten
satellite dish um for each block on the
independent living units which would
just mean that we won't have 55
different satellite dishes being put up
at the site which could be a bit of an
eyesa and so yeah thank you chairman
that's it from
me uh thank thank you Devon um
now uh I have um under the council's
public participation scheme we have
received two submissions one from from
an objector and another from the agent
in line with the public particip ation
scheme I have reviewed the submissions
and will now read them out uh
I uh have determined that that they
should normally be presented within two
minutes uh but um because I'm getting a
rather dry throat at the moment it might
take me a bit longer so the first
representation uh comes from uh Nicholas
Gilmore an objector
objection to the proposed designs for
cun retirement commune elected members
in these strange times when public trust
in our institution is being eroded on a
daily basis the people of our district
are day are today counting on you to
enforce our Le our legally sound local
development and neighborhood plans to
deliver a sustainable prosperous future
for our district ensuring the legacy of
our beautiful Coastal Heritage for
generations to come this carbunco
retirement development was sold as a
sustainable green utopian dream now the
only thing agreeing about these designs
is the odd Bush and there's certainly
nothing utopian either Square design so
in congruous as to be observed absurd
these undignified dystopian boxes
belong elsewhere not blighting the
Burham B the national planning policy
framework mandates you counselors to
ensure that developments add to the
overall quality of the area with
visually attractive buildings synthetic
to the local character and history not
one of these modern Bland designs
achieves this yet the office of report
merely States complete Conformity is not
necessary councilors there is little
historical Conformity here the nearest
comparable flat roof building to these
Bungalows is the high school's 1970s
engineering block used for m m
maintaining machine Machinery not
delivering dignified retirement there is
no Coastal Conformity here no green
thinking and no Community um support
either no one in the district has
written in Praise of these drawings
Burnham is in lament at the prospect of
yet another poorly designed Gateway
development to the town it seems to me
The Architects have ignored the wishes
of the ordinary folk of our district
they've ignored our policies and plans
councilors now is the day to make a
stand against poor and sympathetic
design to seek Vision Elegance dignity
buildings which raise our spirit and
restore our faith in the planning
process to quote the Prince of Wales we
should be building legacies not blots on
our landscape elected members we urge
you to reject these carnus designs do
your duty for the district and seek
better for Burnham thank
you
councelor Morris please turn your video
off
um Tara can you ask the office to show
the layout
um uh Des um slide please yes chairman
of course and there is the other
submission from the agent yes I'm just
going to read that thank you
chairman I want you to catch me breath
can we have the side yeah for sure one
moment thank
you submission two is from Stuart row
agent good afternoon chairman and
members following pre-application
consultation with the council outline
planning Pion was granted for this
development in September 2019 with a
related section 106 agreement signed the
development intends to help meet
important housing needs for elderly
persons in the district that will not be
not be addressed through sites allocated
for new homes in the adopted local plan
the principle of the development the
number and type of units and the mix
including of affordable housing was
approved as part of the outline
permission and the layout of the site
and the means of access to it were also
approved surface and foul water drainage
e ecology archaeology lighting and the
full range of other detailed design
matters are required to be agreed by
planning conditions on the outline
permission and the application and the
applicant is making good progress on
discharging these the submission of
other details required by the one
section 106 agreement such as concerning
the marketing strategy to focus the sale
of the units on residents of the
district is also underway this current
application seeks the council approval
or Reserve matters namely the scale and
appearance of the buildings and the hard
and soft Landscaping of the site it
follows further pre-application meetings
with the council's officers and an
update meeting with members this
application has been prepared in concert
with the applicants e ecologist drainage
consultant and landscape architect with
the intention of ensuring that planting
and surface water storage provide EC
ecological enhancements to the site
including an improved habitat for the
existing population of water vaults this
has meant that open water storage has
been incorporated into the landscape
swells in preference to underground
pipes and the existing ditch has been
retained for its full length and not
altered as approved at outline stage
plants have been selected for their
Wildlife benefit and Immunity value the
bung lows considerably exceed the
minimum floor area set out in guidance
and a contemporary approach to
architecture has been adopted throughout
the development using traditional
building shapes but with a modern Twist
on the use of materials and the
inclusion of some flat roofs to reduce
massing and The Bungalow to the larger
building the applicant is very pleased
to see the recommendation of approval
which reflects much hard work by Council
staff and the development team and the
officer's report is commended to the
committee um I I therefore um U this
after having read that I therefore move
the officers report is that
seconded point of clarity please is that
seconded point of clarity please can I
know if that is seconded no it's not
point of clarity please councelor B
seconded thank you councelor B clity um
councelor Morris you your point of
clarity now we can we can take the
layout down now please Deon well the
thing is Bob
as far as I know and I have still got my
L plates on I didn't think that um
during the public speaking item you
could use uh slides and handouts and
stuff like
that I can oh you can so you can do the
people you members are a reminder that
if you wish to speak on this item please
make this known by using the chat
function within this meeting I will then
come to you in turn Following the Leader
of the
council I will then come to you in turn
please keep your points clear and
succinct my point was that you should
have been using the slide it's not meant
to it's not in the
protocol is that correct councilor
Morris I've made a ruling that that is
correct in this instance now please take
your video switch your video off your
Morris please switch your video off
you're very
important deliberations of this Council
point of
order you have you have a point of order
I'm bound to listen to it councilor
morrris my point of order was that as I
know it when public
speaking you are not supposed to use
slides or or give out handouts or
something like that is that correct Bob
no the the chairman under rule 23
interprets the standing orders of the
council and I I considered that I
considered that that was appropriate
while I was speaking uh with the with
the with the Public's um letters of
information then you are biased um
councelor councelor Morris you can abuse
and Bully me but please do so in another
Forum not at this not at this very
important meeting you are abusing your M
members
uh the it is now for you to um uh ask
your questions or make your points if
councelor morrris doesn't move switch
his uh uh video off it and makes it
difficult for you we'll have to consider
what else to do uh who who Who's I've
got councelor banford to
speak councel banford chairman don't you
go to the ward Members First chairman
exactly that that that U I'm quite happy
to do that but the only ones that have
indicated to speak was councelor Bamford
noair process is you go to the ward MERS
chairman we all indic that we want to
speak we've all indicated that we want
to speak and that's a normal process I
haven't picked that up I'm sorry
councelor stamp you wish to speak now or
councelor schemes or councelor Bell
Council stamp is the ward member and
councelor stamp should be invited to
okay councelor stamp please speak thank
you first of all I think I've been
transported to chelsford looking at that
that presentation and those designs of
the the perspective development we've
got up there but a couple of things
chairman if you'll allow me I'm quite
pleased that this meeting I don't have
any of the developers team sitting in
the auditorium waiting to shout rubbish
as I'm prepared to do my speech and
actually delivering my speech but
another thing I wish to say as well
before we move on and I want this
minuted chairman I'm I'm sure it's
unusual but I don't care I've sat on
this a long time as I came out of a pre
meeting with all the other counselors um
Mr Mok um didn't accost me but I was
trying to leave the meeting and he came
running after me and his words to me
were Wendy I am not your enemy now I
take that as being personal and I want
that minuted I am not happy about being
costed after a private meeting with the
counselors and somebody saying to a
developer saying he's not my enemy thank
you by the bye can I ask where Jackie
longman's report is please chairman can
you ask the officers and because I
noticed at the first application um she
raised or they raised no objection
because it played a vital part to the
reserve
matters also another question before I
deliver my speech
um is the amended market and strategy
attached to this plan in application has
it been
agreed are we allowed to debate
it can I have those questions asked
before I answer before I go on please uh
Devon uh would you like to answer those
questions counc sport I'll pick them up
if you want okay uh Mr Lee thank you
thank chairman um Jackie longman's role
while it's historically was the Urban
Design officer she's no longer in that
post the council no longer has a office
that does that work while miss Longman
is still assisting on the Strategic
allocated sites due to the previous work
she's been involved in her role does not
cover any of the other applications so
the development Management Service is
picking up that work at this time so
there that's why there is no
consultation from an internal Urban
Design office because there is no one
anymore in the council's current
structure furthermore in relation to the
marketing strategy that is something
that is required under the section 106
so it's consideration for this
application thank you chairman okay
thank you all right thank very much Mr
St yep y yeah I I accept I don't agree
with it because um I've been to meetings
where Miss longman's been pre meetings
and she's been putting her views forward
on preapplication so I would have
thought it would be just important that
she commented on something that we're
going to be left with for many many
years but I accept Mr Lee uh Mr Lee what
he's actually said I also wish to query
about the fact that we are not allowed
to debate can I have Clarity because
when we come for these applications
we're told at outline planning we're not
allowed to discuss certain issues
because it comes to reserve matters but
reading the officer's report when
there's things that really should be
cured at Reserve matters we're told it's
not necessary it's no longer me
necessary so I want to make that point
okay moving on the offices say in
3.2.1 this application would not result
in demonstrable harm to the character of
the area area difficult one to quantify
that one I don't agree with the officer
it will totally ruin the area the report
says it is in keeping with character of
the build form of the vicinity how can
that be it's in a field surrounded by
Fields an equestrian center a few houses
along the main road to keep in character
with the design chairman shouldn't it be
in the form of stables and they're only
single height I noticed the officer now
reports it would provide a good level of
living for the future occupiers now
let's analyze this comment I found it
interesting that on the update the
officer turned around and said we take
we can't obviously take any notice of
the expert i6s County Council housing
officer who totally totally and I'm sure
members read it Dale I think his name
was said that they would not support
this application they didn't support it
originally and they weren't to support
it at Reserve
matters I find it really hard that the
this Council does not take any notice of
somebody who has those levels of
qualification and has major concerns
regarding the delivery of care that is
going to be provided at this
development just find it standing MDC
seems to want to support the planning
department department wants to support
the developer who thinks they know
better then somebody's going to be
starting to provide the care and service
for the senior living up
there
5.4.1 I trust members have read this it
just this does not reach most most of
the criteria I'm not going to go through
everything members because the meeting
will go on for like three or four hours
if we do this submitted application does
not Accord with the aims of the oldp how
does a flat roof building with three
stories shops Liv in accom accommodation
ranging in height from 4.2 M which is
13t 9 to 10 m which is over 32' 8 in is
to a huge glass build double story
building in the middle of the
countryside not have a detal effect on
the area or the character or our Coastal
Heritage we are custodians of this
district and planning is one of the
responsibilities we are charged with
great privilege to help shape this
District I cannot support this awful
design as in my view it does not Accord
with our ldp and the officers saying
Conformity is not necessary is unbel
believable it will be a legacy but for
the wrong reasons it does not Accord
with par paragraph 127 of the
mppf as an able resident pointed out in
a letter he wrote to members the nearest
comparable flat roof and actually I
applaud you chairman for reading it out
is that we don't have many flat roofs
we've only got it where they stole
Machinery at the school this application
if AR if approved will erode the unique
chance of Burnham and
saying Burnham and saying a door will
that be opened to everybody to come and
and provide badly designed buildings for
Burnham on Crouch and I'd like the
opportunity when it's debated if I can
to come back I don't want to put up
proposal forward until we've had a full
debate thank
you
um mat do you want to answer any of any
questions there or can I call the next
speaker uh thank you chairman um yeah I
would actually like to come back on a
certain point it's more of clarity um as
members are aware this application is
reserved matters in nature um therefore
it's not a planning application in the
purely legalistic terms of it it is the
skin the color Etc on top of the
skeleton that is the outline planning
permission case law is quite clear that
we are unable to challenge the principal
of a development or matters that have
been accepted at outline stage as part
of Reserve matters um I think we all
accept that the de development of a
field will have some impact on the C of
the area um obviously that's a
subjective opinion so we can part that
but the fact is there will be some form
of development but the council has
accepted that there will be this Quantum
of development on this site the heights
of the commercial buildings have been
accepted through conditions the layout
was accepted the numbers were accepted
and therefore matters such as that are
unable to be Revisited at this time
which is so a lot of the points that
Council stamp raised um really tied into
the outline application matters rather
than anything for this current
submission um and in relation to the
point about the report saying some
matters are for now and some matters are
outline that is how the system works
unfortunately there are things that are
for consideration at outline stage such
as the principle and the matters that
they rais as their Reserve matters that
are considered then and then there are
consideration that Reserve matter stage
and these are different and obviously
each application its own Merit but there
are points unfortunately we are not for
consideration now should not be debated
thank you chairman chairman chairman can
I just say then if that if that was the
case then the officer's report when it
was produced on the original application
should have covered these important
matters that are serious for burnam on
Crouch I don't accept I totally age I
know you're what you're saying um Mr Lee
because you always say it but what your
you're actually doing to burn them on
Crouch is ruining it with this
application with this development with
the style we don't have these type of
buildings now you should as a planning
Authority have have turn around I mean
Mr whatever his name is I forgotten his
name turned around and said they've been
in great consultations with the planning
office how on Earth when you come to
burn them on Crouch do where do you see
big big glass buildings in burnam on
Crouch you are ruining our town with
this type of development thank you
chairman you've
allowed thank thank you um uh now um
councelor SK or Bell which one wishes to
come next can I go next Mr chairman yes
councelor Bell please though thank you
Mr chairman and just following on from
what um council Mrs stamp has
said I'm flabbergasted how members are
supposed to uh look at three stories and
believe they're two is Beyond me utterly
Beyond me it's clearly a three-story
building there when I looked at some of
these I actually miss I thought I was
looking at the new Bradwell Power
Station when I looked at some of these
buildings imagine my horror when I
realized that this was actually the Car
bunkle Care Home facility there is no
resemblance or even referencing to the
local vernacular in these
designs um I don't want to live in
somewhere that looks like Milton King or
near it and in my view this clearly
breaches policies D1 D4 S1 and S8 this
is not design Le it Bears no resemblance
to the local vernacular architecture as
I said and it's just wrong thank you Mr
chairman thank you uh councelor Bell
councelor
schemes yes uh well I first of all agree
with Mr Gilmore's objections and with
councelor stamp and Bell nothing here
raises our Spirits or those of the
people who are likly to live here now
this uh development as councilor Bell
has indicated was given a nickname in
Burnham long ago the carbunkle I have to
say I thought that was unfair at the
time as we didn't know what it was going
to look like um uh even though I have to
say that I have been against the
development because I believe it drives
a coach and horses through our NDP and
our
ldp carbunkle I was against that sub but
now I've seen the designs and apart from
one Street Scene It looks like a prison
made up of prison blocks or in one case
a supermarket these have nothing to do
with the rural setting nothing to do
with the architecture of nearby Burnham
and I in clear breach of policy D1 of
the ldp and I quote policy D1 design
quality and built environment 0.1
respect and enhance the character all
development must respect and enhance the
character and local context and make a
positive contribution in terms of a
architectural style now those are the
two key points right at the top of
D1 for me it's pretty clear that this
does a very opposite of respect and
enhance the character on local uh
context it's a negative contribution in
terms of architectural style and for me
it has to be redesigned to look at least
more Rural and more human I cannot
support this in its current form and my
impression is this view is shared across
the rural town of burnam on
Crouch um thank you councilor schemes um
now I have got a long list of speakers
um and the order I've got them in I
should I should the order that I've got
them uh jotted down I'll um I'll call
councelor
banford
thank you
chairman um I was not at the meeting
where this was agreed at outline and I
am totally gobsmack that this has been
agreed for
outline um I won't go into design
because most of the other Ward members
um have mentioned design and I totally
agree with everything that they've
said um interestingly you have on the
design side um the mixed use block which
is the shops which is traditional in
design which doesn't look so bad but why
is the rest of the site so different so
modern and so out of keeping with
everything in the district um so on that
point I totally agree it it's um not in
accordance with our ldp um D1
policy now I've got a couple of other
issues that I want to
raise um because I wasn't at the outline
um I don't understand and I don't see
any mention of this anywhere about how
the district council is going to be
involved with the management of this um
development because it's there's so many
different things on this site um and
some of the conditions on this new
application are restricting things to do
with the maintenance building and now
we've got the satellites um on the
building satellite dishes and um
restrictions on permissive development
but what about all these other things
are they covered in something I just
want to know like the fact that the
apartments all for key
workers um we've got a medical center
there's all sorts of other things that
need some kind of control so I don't
know how um we've addressed this as a
council so that's one
question that I'd liked answered now I
realize this application we can only
comment on scale appearance and
Landscape now scale is height um I know
um I thought I understood Matt Lee to
say that that is not the case I think it
is that we can comment on the height of
buildings under scale which is what
we're looking at um so that is not in
accordance with um
rldp um the landscape part of it the
soft Landscaping does include the
suds now I'm a bit confused about this
because the lead flood um people at the
county did comment last time there have
been some alterations and I can't see
that it's being commented on again in
this report although it seems to
indicate there's some kind of separate
application on this so that's my other
question is is this application with
regard to Suds coming back to this
Council um well to members or is it just
going to be an officer um
discussion um my other point is about
the fa path at
3137 on page
21 um which mentions a bridal way now if
we have an equestrian center
nearby um how is this going to be
accommodated it's only mentioned it's
not a condition of in any sense of the
word with regard to Bridal way it
mentions footpath but not Bridal way so
that's another question
um so in effect the other
design uh problem which is the
appearance is to do with the fact that
you've got these communal areas in front
of the Bungalows which could be
accommodated for allotments and other
things but in the middle of it all
you've got a visitor's parking space now
how is that acceptable so I don't see
that that's acceptable and that would
come under Pol
T2 so all in all I'm not happy with this
development on various grounds I won't
make a proposal I'll leave that to the
ward members um but I think I've covered
quite a lot there's quite a lot of
questions there thank you very much
chairman um uh can I remind members um
that uh to be as brief as possible um
normally the uh there's a three minute
uh rule um but because this is a very
important issue I'm I'm being a bit
[Music]
LS
chairman you may need to repeat yourself
we lost you for a minute
there uh um yeah uh I did I I after
councilor banford spoke I did ask
members to um uh as brief as as possible
this is an important a very important
issue uh for us to debate um so I don't
want to be too harsh on the three minute
rule but um we need there's a lot of
members wishing to speak so we need to
uh move on um uh so councelor Chana is
the next speaker I've
got uh thank you chairman I do apologize
if I keep looking down because I've got
various sheets of paper here and it's
quite difficult because I've lost one
thing on my other screen that I wanted
to refer to chairman um I'd just like to
say chairman I I think the officer at
the start said the outline application
had been about access and layout
predominantly referred to appearance
landscaping and scale and said layout
density um urbanization or impacts of
infrastructure on this particular
application wasn't to be discussed um
however chairman I just would like to
say I agree with elements that councilor
stamp Bell and uh banford have now
bought up but chairman I think what I
must ask questions on and I you know um
uh at the um outline stage I recall very
clearly um hearing about what the
properties were be marketed for and also
about ecology and at that report the
report was quite specific chairman it
said at the reserved matters stage to
review the effect of potential
recreational pressure from development
on nearby nationally and internationally
important nature conservation sites and
Implement a scheme blah blah blah blah
and then it also said that would be done
by a 106 chairman now I've looked at the
106 also in that same meeting we were
told training and education obligations
would be applied we heard in that report
about 100 jobs coming and they would be
doing it for local people chairman I've
looked at the one 106 and I'm afraid
chairman I do have a problem and I hear
what Mr matle says because we've had the
outline application and we M matters of
the 106 however in my own mland Ward at
a planning meeting um there was a
reserve matters application came forward
it was recommended for refusal by
officers on the basis that it did not
meet the essence of the outline
application it wasn't in the spirit of
it now I've looked at the um 106
agreement for the outline uh which
obviously has a great influence on this
development I could see nothing in the
obligations about training education and
most certainly I could not see the
ecology covered and in the report at the
SK for members today on page um 38 it
does refer under paragraph 5.9
5.91 that it is addressed in the 106 and
the outline stage there is no
requirement to revisit here I'm sorry
chairman I think we do need to revisit
because I cannot see under the 106
anything that um was uh promised through
the report the officers wrote at the
outline stage saying quite clearly at
reserved matter stage to review the
effect of potential potential
recreational pressure I believe there is
recreational pressure should this go
ahead chairman um and I won't
prevaricate I've got a load more to say
but I'll say they were largely covered
far by Bell um SC Council of Bale
Stamper Bamford to me I would align it
with the buy development that's
happening now where I think it looks
grotesque the new development happening
there I thought some of it was an
industrial site buildings coming forward
and as for um flat roofs on Bungalows
they just look like blocks so I think
there's design issues councelor chel
thank you um uh Mr Lee or Devon would
you like to respond to Mrs banford uh to
councelor banford uh and Mrs Channer
Please Mr Lee yeah thank chairman sorry
yeah I was just finishing typing a
message to someone um sorry spit one the
troubles with doing it all remotely it's
a little bit slower um in relation to
councelor banord points um yeah SS is a
condition imposed on the outline matters
uh I think it's condition 12 off the top
of my head um and obviously that will be
submitted as part of it uh approval of
details just like with any application
so it's not a consideration for this
application um but that's similar to
obviously infrastructure and things like
that also which are required through the
section 106
um the relation to the key workers point
that has never been in any of the
officers reports because while the
applicant has indicated their key
workers for his business key worker is a
specific definition and therefore we
haven't used it as officers because it
doesn't fall under that definition the
affordable housing requirement it was
policy compliant um or is polic
compliant and that is covered through
the section 106 as well um relation to
councilor chisp in relation to ecology
that's in relation to Rams and if my
understanding is that that is within the
original section 106 requirement for
that
um so but at the time we weren't sure of
the figure so we were a little bit more
ambiguous on the wording but we've now
moving that forward obviously as members
fully aware the SPD is currently out for
consultation for an Ethics wide uh SPD
which will deal with those matters um so
I think that's answered the questions
chairman thank you thank you um the next
speaker is um one of members for sou
councilor fluka I have aoun
fluka
councelor
Fluker councilor Fluker not there Mrs
Chanel what was you
saying um chairman with all due respect
um to Mr Lee and I do respect a lot of
what Mr Lee has to say quite clearly I
don't see within the report anywhere Mr
Lee's at I'm sorry I have looked at the
106 I cannot see about Rams or anything
that might allude to it and it was was
quite clear at Reserve matters stage to
review the effect of potential
recreational pressure I see nothing in
the report aside from what was on page
38 5.9 5.91 telling us it's already been
dealt with the outline stage and the
okay M you the reserves a very important
matter through chairman for clarity the
the reviewing of it is in relation to
seeking the contribution what this is is
we are now have the figure agreed
through the SPD when at the time we
didn't know what the figure would be
it's it was pretty much standard wording
for all of our larger schemes that we
were doing of 10 and over at that time
so that the payment is now based around
what it would be required now at the
time we didn't know what that was so we
had to provide some level of flexibility
for the council to be able to seek an
appropriate payment in the future so
that is how it was dealt with and it's
consistent across all the large schemes
at that time thank you chairman um thank
thank you councelor Fluker are you with
us
yet councelor Fluker chairman I I think
councelor herd and others well before me
um I think that's signal well you're
down you're you're down on my list next
but if you wish to wait um I'll call
councelor herd I'm up as I'm see you and
hear
yous with councilor herd Council f is
having trouble um thank you chairman um
yes I've listened very carefully to what
um other counselors have um have said I
have to agree I'm going to address the
appearance and scale I have to say um I
agree with councilor schemes it looks
just like a prison it's completely out
of character uh for Burnham and more of
a new town style um as far as the scale
goes I think it is far too it is too
high uh and the reason I suspect that uh
refu trucks are not allowed into the
development would be to cram yet more
units in there um anyway I'm very
concerned about the lack of parking
spaces um because there's less than one
per um per unit less than one space per
unit um and I think it is um although
it's not part of this application to
expect somebody with venture to ride 2
miles into town uh is is rather Beyond
me but the other thing that I'm
concerned about is the less than
25 uh square meters of amenity space and
the move to Outlaw any ouses or um sheds
uh we have to bear in mind that if we
are expecting older people and uh people
with dementia they're going to have to
have some kind of uh space either to do
some gardening or or something like that
so I think as far as the appearances
scale goes um I think I've said I agree
with what all of the other previous
speakers have said and that's uh my
addition to it thank you
chairman um thank you councelor herd uh
councelor
M yes good afternoon um Mr chairman um
I'm little confused uh I looked at the
original
application you're you're
fading you're breaking up councelor
Ma I'm breaking up can you hear me
now can you hear me now yes thank you
okay um
yes and the um approval and the um
conditions that were applied to that
approval I worked out that there were 11
or so that were to be considered at
Reserve matters um some of those have
obviously been discussed very uh
admirably by everybody else which I
agree with size scale fat roofs Etc um
there there's a few points that I I did
want to come on to um one
was company um can I interrupt you
councelor Ma you're you're just breaking
up as far as I'm conc concerned I don't
know whether officers are actually
hearing what you're saying or other
members for you chairman it's yeah I as
I can't hear this so I wouldn't be able
to reply to any questions at this stage
yeah councilor ma can can I call you
back later perhaps you have a better
connectivity
yes thank you uh councelor
darham yeah good afternoon
chairman
can you hear me yes thank you
and yeah sorry and see you oh dear oh
dear okay thank you yeah I'm going to be
very contentious here
um uh and I've listened very carefully
to what everybody's been saying and I've
read obviously all of the papers first
thing I would say is we shouldn't we
shouldn't really be in this position uh
I wasn't at the meeting where the
outline was granted goodness knows how
it was
uh how how it was given outline
approval
um but it was uh I I I've just beyond my
comprehension how uh this development of
this scale in this location got through
but we are where we are we know what we
can uh we can uh decide on today um and
let's face it design is very much a
matter of personal um opinion and and I
don't have a major issue with it um I I
think it doesn't look so much like a
prisoners it looks a bit more like a
hospital but you know it's a it's a
modern building um and it's a modern
complex personally my personal view is
that um I don't find it terribly
unattractive uh because the entire
development is in the same sort of
design
um but uh yes I said you know we we
shouldn't be discussing it anyway you
know what is the alternative the
alternative is a development full of
chintzy little red brick um things like
arms houses um you know we need to be
looking forward I think this is
innovative development um and as I said
um you know I I personally don't have
have a problem with it but I don't think
it should have been granted uh
permission in the first place uh nice
and brief for you chairman thank you uh
councelor darham councelor
lagen
thank you chairman um members uh
strangely enough I find myself agreeing
with Council darham that I feel that the
the application shouldn't be be where we
are but we are where we are um pick a
point that Devon raised earlier on she
said it wouldn't be reasonable to object
to the size and scale I would have
thought it's very very reasonable to
object to the size and scale um because
I think that the looking at the
presentation um I and I won't go over
what other members have said because I
completely agree with them I completely
agree with Mr Gilbo and the other
objectives at s because it's too big
it's too ugly it's not in keeping with
the area and I'd much rather see chiny
little red brick arms houses that
keeping character of the area that don't
ruin it and make it look like a cester
development um it doesn't aord with the
ldp uh I think it should be challenged I
think it's absolutely awful and I can't
apologize enough to the people who who
have been looking at this and have the
potential to have this monstrosity on
their doorstep thank you chairman thank
you Council lag councelor
Swain councelor Swain yes um thank you
chairman
um I have few some points one or two
specific ones and one more General one
which does have a bearing on the
appearance scale design and other
aspects under consideration today but
which I'm not sure can be dealt with um
I was puzzled to try and think um where
I'd seen this and why I hadn't voted um
because I would certainly have voted
against it had I been there then I
realized this was um passed the outline
permission was given in January of last
year when I and a number of other
members were not on the council and it
appears to me there are a number of
other existing um counselors who either
weren't there or wish to distance
themselves from the decision um my two
specific points Point are relating to
the walkway between the main blocks um
and I don't know whether the argument
about breaking up the scale um counts to
me it makes it look more
industrial um and I don't know what the
point of it is um the second referring
back to councilor bamford's point about
Suds um the suds alteration is a um a
change to the
Landscaping um and um
I would suggest that as a condition that
um we the developer needs to have the
agreement of the local flood Authority
that it is acceptable before beginning
commencement of development um not
before first occupation of anything but
before the development Starts Now from I
come to my more General point the
underlying problem which has given rise
to so much of the complaints and so on
uh is that this development has tried to
do two completely different things and
squash them into one development on the
one hand the idea of a retirement
village to me is a solar site separate
from developments has its own style
design is um uh integral um may even be
a gated
community on the other hand um
affordable housing and accommodation for
assisted living um is precisely the sort
of um accommodation that needs to be
integrated socially and in terms of
Design Within the um local settlement um
and I don't see how the two can be um
put together now the the implications of
this um relate to the
facilities uh and the
retail uh and social um uh facilities
that are en visaged for this development
um I cannot see how um outside use of
these uh will be avoided and I can see
people coming um from outside um in
numbers to go to the takeaway or the
cafe or the the shop premises um and
furthermore since this is essentially a
commercial approach commercial operation
it will be in the interest of the
management and The Operators to
encourage Outsiders to come in now to my
mind this um has implications for
parking um for safety of residents who
will be either elderly or in Scooters or
uh otherwise vulnerable um and with both
parking and safety implications um I
don't know whether this can be covered
by conditions in some way or whether
we're talking about something more
fundamental about the design and and
layout thank you councelor Swain um uh
Mr Lee do you want to respond to those
issues thank you chairman um OB a couple
of issues since last time I spoke that
have been raised
um we're just looking at what those
different things right um obviously as
members are aware the council is an
entity and it determined the application
so whether or not members were on the
committee previously it's not Material
consideration as part of this
application um the council determined
the application and it is just the
reserve matters to do with that outline
um things such as SS I said before
they've already been uh required through
conditions at the outline stage and it's
not reasonable to impose additional
conditions when this has been done
because that was the correct way to do
it the reason we use things such as
before occupation is because that
actually is what government's guidance
is um it's not requiring the details
must be um submitted before occupation
it means it must be in place it's within
the occupy the applicant's gift to
submit the details as early or as late
as they wish but until they are in place
to mitigate the harm the properties
can't be occupied so I can understand
where counc Swain is coming from and in
reality it's very likely they will put
the conditions in sooner rather than
later because it will affect how the
development comes forward but government
guidance is that you shouldn't put
conditions on that say pre-commencement
unless they're really exceptionally
needed that would normally be
archaeology protection of trees Etc
because they can't once a shovel goes in
the ground you can't undo the harm but
things such as Suds or matters such as
that it's about miting the harm once
occupied so that's why they've been
worded the way they are thank you
chairman thank you Mr Lee
um I propose that we refuse councelor
Morris can I read out uh councelor May's
question yeah but I propose we refuse
this um M councelor Morris you can't
propose that and I'll explain why in a
minute uh councilor May said should
should we not be discussing the reserve
matters that were outlined on the
approval from 2018 these are 11 and
relate to conditions one landscape
appearance and scale condition two I've
lost it now condition two
uh materials of all boundary fences and
walls Etc condition three soft
Landscaping condition four parking
condition seven housing mix condition 19
Cycles condition 22 lighting
strategy condition 23 Waste Management
plan condition 24 Superfast Broadband
condition 25 Eco
enhancements condition 28 shopping hours
if we don't discuss these conditions
under Reserve matters they will be
missed and left to whom uh Mr
Lee to you chairman um well obviously we
are discussing things such as land Hing
scow and matter such that but also the
matters such as the opening hours are
and certain additional aspects in
landscaping Etc are covered on the
conditions here um housing mix Etc so we
are doing them um
to my opinion um I don't know if there's
a specific issue that councelor has that
we think we missed in particular but as
you know OB all members aware we've been
discussing quite length Landscaping
scale and appearance and yeah the other
matters are generally covered in the
office report thank you chairman Council
Morris why we can't I can't take another
proposal at the moment is we're debating
a motion that's on the table um if you
do not agree with with the motion then
you'll have the opportunity to vote
against it if that vote against the
motion is if that vote against the
motion is carried you will then have the
opportunity to propose a new motion uh
councelor White
please sorry Mr chairman and I'm just
the customer and just briefly I've got
two points a lot of more have been
brought up obviously the scale Mass uh
and bul and design which is POL d one
but the other one is um in the
development that was east of um lambrook
way we' previously agreed there would be
a bridal way and obviously we'
previously agreed with this one um now
if it is approved I would like to
propose that one of the conditions is
there is a condition that there is a
bridal way in place because it was um
agreed in principle by members um so I'd
like to ensure that this is included but
otherwise I agree with all everything
that I wanted to raise has already been
raised thank you for letting me speak
than thank you councelor
Bassinger one second one
second there we are thank you Mr
chairman thank you I don't know if
anyone can hear me um Mr chairman my
from my perspective um I am the one of
the directors of a housing estate
embarking in Essex and I would just like
to point out from sort of on the ground
some of the main issues with design
which are really to do with people's
usability and this
design actually is is abhorrent to me
because I can see the main problems are
parking there's not enough and that's
one of the main issues on the Estates
which I'm a director is the biggest
concern the other one is waste if anyone
thinks that people are going to put all
their rubbish in little bins and then
people are going to come and take that
rubbish and put it in other bins and
that will work I can tell you it's
absolutely ridiculous the other issue is
about storage the there are going to be
wheelchairs there going to be prams
there are going to be buggies these
things need somewhere to go and to have
areas where there are no private spaces
no Gardens is absolutely inhuman so when
we talk about design and architecture we
should also think about how that works
with people and I can tell you this is
an inner city slum being brought to burn
them on Crouch thank you very much thank
you councelor basser councelor Nan
thank you very much chairman uh much has
been made about uh how this proposed
development matches with the local
vernacular um the recognized foremost
architectural historian Nicholas pevner
actually describes the vernacular of
Burnham so we don't need to uh uh
trouble ourselves too much about what it
is whilst he doesn't use the rather
derogatory term that we've heard chintzy
he does actually talk about burn B's
attraction being teres of low houses
some with porches he talks about a
pallet of red and white he talks about a
lovable Place houses of Special Value
and of urban scale that's burnam's
vernacular not the proposal that we have
here on the
table councel Nan thank you uh councelor
Harker which I've got Tara I've got as
the last speaker unless councilor fluka
wishes to um speak as the world member
for southminster otherwise councel har
is the last speaker I've got
listed counc Harker right thank you can
you hear me yes yeah okay I think the
the appearance of this development is
truly
awful it's worse than the site at South
mden it's a prison blocks not out of 10
the applicants have surpassed themselves
in awfulness I'm not going to vote for
it the benefits of the scheme do not
outweigh the disadvantages the building
design is totally totally out ofke
keeping with Burnham thank you thank you
councelor Harker councelor Fluker do you
wish to speak
now yeah thank you and and I think
councelor stamp wants to come second um
chairman
you know we are where we are with this
this this development has got outlin
planning permission and we are dealing
with Reserve matters here and I think
that when we consider this we shouldn't
lose sight of the fact of the fact that
it does bring some very good things in
particular 30% affordable housing it it
provides homes for the elderly and jobs
for local people which are obviously
much needed uh and of course other
facilities although we don't understand
who's going to have access to those
particularly the swimming pool and the
sports facilities and Doctor surgeries
and dent and Opticians Etc I mean I I
I'm I'm always pleased to uh have an
update on history from councelor nun but
I I hope he remembers that one of the
most iconic uh buildings in the UK uh of
modernist architecture is actually in
burnam mon Crouch and it does actually
have a flat roof and that was built in
1934 I think but I'm sure you're correct
me if I'm wrong so uh there we go so
chairman what concerns me about this is
is that there is an officer's
recommendation for approval and we know
that we're talking about subjective
matters and I guess from the debate
today where this might end up our
decision May well be uh reflected upon
by a third party and having said that
chairman I think members should be
mindful of the local development plan
and particularly uh around some of the
images and some of the narratives that
appear in there uh and indeed the
inclusion of flat roofs Avant Garden
contemporary designs and and I think the
other document that's very very
important for us all to understand it
has been around a long time is the
modern design guide and again on pages 6
23 25 26 30
31 uh 34 and 39 I'm sure councelor Mo if
you turn it around the other way people
will be able to read it and then I can
take a photograph and then we can rattle
that one off to the uh monitor oh put it
down didn't like that okay fluka looks
terrible is the boat disappearing okay
disappearing
anyway to
theer you are corer so chairman this
right okay so um chairman I do
think I do think chairman I do think
chairman that members should be mindful
of this and the other thing is Mr Lee
spoke to the quantum of the development
which is a new one to me but I think
we've already agreed to allow so many uh
types of dwellings on the site so
whatever comes back it isn't going to
reduce it now I I I sort of get it what
the burnam members are saying I do get
it that maybe they want something you
know more red brick uh with not flat
roofs but if you start putting higher
roofs on this chairman it's going to be
more visual outside people are going to
see it more when they come into the town
so we do have a contemporary design but
if the members from Burnham say that
they want these buildings to have uh
traditional style Roofing on them
they're obviously going to be much
taller and and the developer is not
going to reduce the number of properties
on the site so chairman you know my my
view is not very far away from councelor
dams I think that we've all had I think
we've all had emails over the last week
or two uh from residents were worried
about this I know it's not a huge amount
but nevertheless their views should be
taken into consideration but chairman it
does concern me that many of the design
aspects that we're looking at today are
in the M design guide and they do appear
in the local development plan and
members should be mindful of that uh and
chairman just to save uh councelor
Morris jumping in um and I'm sure he'll
second me I'm sure he's smiling now I'm
sure he'll can I say it's a pleasure to
see you in my dining room um can I can I
propose chairman that we have a recorded
vote and I'll ask councilor Mo to second
that he's shouting away but he hasn't
got his microphone on
com thank you councelor fluka I have a I
I have a late councel Morris please I
have a late entry um Council shy wishes
to speak
Council thank you chairman why did you
not why did you not declare a pecuniary
interest at the start of this councilor
Morris please please let us proceed if
this wasn't if this wasn't you guys put
forward it and
never please
is this councelor
shy uh thank you chairman very much um
originally I voted against this plan um
and I agree with very much of what's
been said um today um but I would like
to sort of um drag some positives um
here if I may um Devon um did indicate
that the independent living blocks um
had solar panels on the roof um I would
like to ask please if all the flat roofs
um are intending to have solar panels um
and if not uh why not uh because if we
have to have flat roofs it would be um a
jolly uh positive thing thank you
chairman thank thank thank you now I um
I know councelor stamp has a query on I
think
procedure um uh but I think it will all
become clear so I shall move move on and
uh Mr Lee wishes to respond to members
Mr Lee why can't I why can't I ask that
question please councelor uh councelor
voice because you don't know what my
question is going to
be what was your question um I would
like to ask um the officer Mr Lee that
based on a a meeting that I attended the
other day with him and based on the
majority of what people who've spoken at
this meeting uh modern District Council
has the ability to withdraw a already
approved planning application now based
on that and if it is true and I'm sure
Mr Lee can spout some more case law at
us um but I'd be very interested to have
an actual um proper opinion and view if
this can be done and if it can be done
why can't we look at it for something
that is so abor and not in the right
place okay coun St you've made your
point uh Mr Lee would you like to
respond first to that and then to the
general debate thank you chairman
um Council referencing a meeting or
discussions that were had around a
planning application that was submitted
that would um on a single dwelling um it
was at one end of the develop of the
built form and previously uh a similar
form of development had been
granted at the other end of the building
um that in included personal
circumstance which I won't go into
because it's not appropriate for this
debate but officers had concerns with
the design of the development but they
waited the material considerations of
the special circumstance in favor of the
application however the weight to be
attributed to them was for one of the
BET phrase undermined or reduced due to
the fact that a similar form of special
circumstance have been put forward for
the other form of development so what
that is is not that we are looking to
withdraw an application what that is
saying is that if they wish to bring
forward development a they would not
bring forward development b or vice
versa we would expunge the permission
which is totally different to us looking
to just quash a permission that already
exists those are very different
circumstances um in relation to that so
I hopefully I've answered counselor
stamps and point on that um in relation
to a couple points um so sorry no on Mr
Lee please carry on okay um in relation
to council herd and someone else ra as
well and I forgot to mention before is
that actually the car parking is in
accordance with the development plan
policies so um that is at a level that
is accordance with our plan so we
shouldn't can't really object to that in
principle unfortunately members um just
want to talk about obviously the design
issues that have been raised um and
obviously I can understand that certain
members have concerns with that um it is
an interesting point as Rik said you
know outline planning permission has
been granted for the site so we have
accepted that a level of built form will
happen on this site furthermore layout
was agreed at outline stage so that
Quantum of built form the size roughly
of the blocks in relation to commercial
um and the medical Etc has all been
already agreed and is accepted so the
level of development the level of built
form Etc is not something for
consideration at this time it um and in
relation to the design points um
specifically um I know members comments
about what the policy says but it's also
important to note that actually the uh
D1 also does allow for Innovative
designs um obviously things such as this
are subjective as Council fluka has said
before and I think I said at the
beginning um and obviously as members
know we are not here to be the Arbiters
of good taste we need to assess scheme
and where there is demonish or harm um
there is a large formal development
going on this site you can't deny that
but as I said that's already been agreed
I think it is of a Quantum it's of a
level that allows it to have to a
certain a standalone design it is a
modern design but planning encourages
you know designs of its time rather than
just looking backwards and trying to
replicate that you know we have to think
forward and you know whether this
accepted or not you know but a modern
design schemes are coming forward and
they will be of their time in 20 30
years and that is a material
consideration just because it is
different on its own is not a problem in
principle furthermore the commercial
properties would are likely to always
appear as a commercial property and have
a commercial scale um as explained
previously they the heights of these
have been restricted through condition
but no concern was ever raised in
principle to having buildings of this
height in principle at the outline stage
and has been accepted so if members are
to to have reservations about the scheme
and they need to make sure that they
specifically relate to the points that
are for consideration here not for
matters that have already been agreed by
the council because that would be a
difficult position to put the counseling
thank you chairman um can you um answer
the Mrs Sha's question about solar
panels um Mr
[Music]
Lee oh sorry i' add myself on Mike they
are on all the commercial buildings yes
all the flat roofs thanks
um thank you um right members I think
that concludes everything we've now move
to um a a recorded vote that was
proposed and
seconded um although we do a recorded
vote anyway but um it will be um minuted
as a recorded vote um and I therefore
put the motion that I I moved ear on
that the officer's recommendation be
approved um can um Tara you take the
caller role please do you want me to
leave the room it's Council Hall and
Hall
um councelor
H yeah do you want me to leave if you're
if you're not voting um yes it might be
preferable it might be preferable so if
you just take yourself out lovely okay
thank you oh hold
[Music]
on I've got a message saying from Mrs
Chana that's saying people still want to
speak but I think everybody has spoken
and covered most of the issues all of
the
issues sorry
councelor Council SK and councel Nan
asked to come back on um that's not
about the debate that's that's to argue
with another member yeah um uh so so um
Mr Lee
um help me please there was no suggested
new uh conditions do chairman obviously
on the members update there is some uh
Amendment additional condition and an
amendment um yeah but yeah there is
nothing through the debate now thank you
okay right thank you uh Tara take the
vote please yes certainly chairman so
just to confirm the members update gave
an amendment to condition two and then
the the officer during the presentation
referred to an amendment to condition 10
and an additional condition 19 chairman
so members I'm going to call your name
out
alphabetically chairman if I may come in
I put forward a proposal that if the
application was approved that the bridal
we would be one of the conditions you
did indeed uh uh Miss White sorry
chairman yes sorry about that have you
got a problem with the brid way my
understanding was that was included in
the section 106 agreement okay it
wouldn't be as part of this application
agreed but you think that's that that is
sure enough rather than having it as a
condition well once if we've dealt with
it outline stage it shouldn't be you
wouldn't repeat it at Reserve matter
stage okay thank you very much uh Tara
proceed with the
vote thank you chairman and members I
call your names out alphabetically if
you could just respond advising if
you're for against or abstaining please
um can just confirm this is Council bill
just confirm what we're voting for for
the actual officer recommendation or the
other proposal please no the officer's
recommendation Tara carry on thank you
councelor Bamford
against thank you councelor
Bassinger against counc
missel
against councelor Bell against
councelor
Boyce councelor Mrs
Channer um can you see me I've Lost You
Yes can see okay I can't see myself so
um all I can say is against thank you
councel
dorham uh I'm for see councelor
Edwards
against councelor Mrs
Fleming
against Council flu
for thank you councelor Harker
against councelor
herd
against councelor Hull he's not in the
bit meeting councelor
Jarvis
against councelor
Lan
Maz again
against councelor
Morris definitely
against definitely against
sorry sorry councelor nun against thank
you councelor
shessy
against Sidle against excuse me
councelor skines against thank coun
stamp
against Stills
against councelor Swain against
councelor Mrs
Thompson
um sorry could you repeat that Council M
Thompson sorry thank you very much
white
against chairman that's four in favor
and 21 against thank you that motion is
therefore uh uh lost uh and I look for a
um a proposal to um refuse the
application I'm quite happy to uh
propose
chairman seconded Council I can second
that um chairman can I have a recorded
propose a recorded vote please on the
motion thank
you um
um we need to know re refusal yes please
coun Mr Lee um I've listened to the
members debate obviously and picked out
obviously some of the points um and
obvious keep saying obviously um and we
need to consider the fact that it is
reserved matters so
for um from picking up the various
points that members have said I would
suggest it would be and this obviously
would still be delegated specifically
for wording to officers but something
along the lines of the design of the
proposed development due to its modern
nature would not reflect the character
and appearance of the area and would be
detrimental to The Wider vernacular and
cont to policies and then we'd list them
off I I would have problems with the
modern because that sounds a bit loaded
to me it's just I'd keep it just to the
design if you talk about the modern
nature it sounds like we're against
modernity we're not against modernity
but we're against this particular design
with with its block with its block
buildings well said CH SC what about
rudimentary design would members be
happy with again rudimentary they could
query that no it's uh it's basically
that it doesn't do what policy D1 an
enhance
character have you got that Mr Lee y as
I said you can you put some wording
around that yeah as I said we we if
members are happy to give the exact
wording to officers but we've got the
thrust of something along lines of
design of the proposed development would
not reflect the uh character and
appearance of the AA and would be
detrimental to The Wider you know
something along those lines and that and
that's proposed and seconded yes hang on
I've not I I put the proposal and not
been able to speak sorry sorry I'm just
I just for formality I'm I'm not going
to deny you or um Mrs banford I think
wishes to speak as well I'd like to know
if Mr Lee would you would you be able to
include or do you recommend you include
the policies D1 3.1 3.3 the mppf
paragraph 127 policy X part four and
also the NDP Heritage and character 9.3
hc. 2
ho8 would you be able to look at those
in detail because that's what I chairman
obviously our we would obviously talk
about policy S1 and D1 which are
obviously the ones that we used with
design in relation to our policies and
we talk about the mppf we just use that
in our recent reviews was a h obviously
it's a a multi-layer document and I
wouldn't want to tie us in too much too
early if that makes sense yeah but
sometimes you'll refer to it in the
office's details and you don't so I just
fine and we would if for example as with
any application if it go to appeal we
would pull out the appropriate
paragraphs of the mppf which relate to
the reason for refusal but normally in
the reason for refusal we only state the
mppf because obviously more you say less
wiggle room you've got one of a better
phrase exactly and with all due respect
I know you're going to try and but stop
me councelor Bo but with all due respect
I've sat on many appeals and I've heard
sometimes a
representation I've heard their
representations that can be made and I
just want to make this watertight so it
doesn't cost this District money we all
need we're all aware of the position
we're in but it's important that this is
watertight so thank you
chairman um uh Mr Lee you're satisfied
that you can find a a a viable reason uh
planning reason uh on policy uh for the
proposal um you chairman obviously as
we've said before design is subjective
um officers don't have a issue with it
but as members decision makers it's well
within their gift to come to a different
decision and um obviously we have
policies and I said like the mppf that
highlight the importance of design so
yeah I think we can come with a reason
for refusal thank you thank you very
much uh Tara would you now put the uh
there is a recorded vote requested and
seconded can you please put the um call
the
rooll uh yes certainly chairman um
councilor banford did ask to speak
chairman just so you're
aware oh oh yes I'm sorry I'm sorry
councelor banford um uh you wish to
speak on the proposal please do so yes
thank thank you uh chairman
um I think the design part of it
although um Mr Le has covered most of it
it's the Conformity of this development
where you've got the block of mixed um
you know the shop premises which are
traditional and the rest of it which is
not so it's not in Conformity as a whole
so I don't know that can be incorporated
in our reason for refusal I also
wondered if we could use as a reason for
refusal policy T2 because I did raise
this issue of the areas around the
Bungalows where they were
proposing um to have allotments and
other facilities but also have visitors
parking which didn't seem to be
acceptable in terms of accessibility
um and policy T2 so can we use policy2
as well um see chairman um those are
additional areas of of communal space
um I would have concerns about that
forming a sustainable reason for refusal
um if I'm honest my professional opinion
but it's obvious it's in members gift
but I think it would be
difficult banford chairman can I also
raise um the issue that councelor white
made about the brid away now I'm sure I
I can't look at the report at the moment
but I'm sure there was a condition about
the footpath in this reserved matters
and it doesn't mention
briway so I want to make sure chairman
the bridal way was I said was if I'm
correct through the sexual the current
application about the foot path is about
during construction process to make sure
it's kept clear which is slightly
different right thank you chairman um
Tara again can you put the vote
please uh yes chairman chairman for
clarity does that include councelor
Bamford and I'd probably need a little
bit better on what her actual objection
is for forming the reason for refusal
wording no I I thought I thought I
thought that uh that you explained to
council banford why they wouldn't be I
did but counil St second it that's what
I'm getting at councelor stamp said
she'd second it so in theory I know it's
up to you but I just want
Clarity um well
if I think in these circumstances
providing we've got a viable sustainable
reason for objection there is a danger
in in in putting uh reasons for refusal
in that are not really sustainable and
you have given your professional opinion
that they're not really sustainable but
I'm open to me members if they wish if
members wish this to uh to happen then
it's up to them but my advice would be
to to stick with the uh the present
reason for
refusal inur that we just stick with the
one reason for refusal if it's a strong
one because I know before now we've lost
appeals on a weaker weaker reason so I
think we go strong and try and win in
case they appeal for you chairman my
advice for all members in any
application would be to not say the few
re Poss uh few reasons for refusal as
possible it's about having the correct
ones ones that are robust um it's always
difficult in a hearing or public inquir
if it does go to appeal if you're
arguing relatively weak reasons refusal
that then undermine the overall
perception of the council's decision
that would be my advice as always thank
you chairman thank you may I just come
back Mr chairman please do very I just
want to quote for members
um number four in policy T2 which says
improve accessibility to buildings
streets and public spaces particularly
for those with Mobility
impairments so that's part of T2 now if
you've got a public o o open area with
vehicles inside there where they're
going to be gardening Etc that to me um
is is right I mean it it is against that
policy okay uh Mi uh Mr Mr Lee are you
sticking to your
advice yes chairman yes I am thank thank
thank you thank you Council banford uh
Tara please um call the
rooll uh now uh members um Tara is going
to uh call the uh role in a second uh
and it is for ref uh that the
application be refused for the reason
that Mr Lee has has outlined and again
if you're for that you say for if you're
against against or abstain Tara please
proceed uh thank you chairman uh so
starting with councelor banford please
so just to conf just to clarify then
we're we're opposing this just on
design yes that that is correct are you
for the proposal or I am for the
proposal thank you Mr chairman thank you
thank you chairman Council Bassinger
four councelor Miss Beal
four councelor bell
four councelor Boyce
four coun Mrs
Channer uh sorry um uh four can you hear
me yes we can hear you thank my mic up
and down no we can hear you thank thank
you councelor councelor Duram I wish to
abstain
please thank you councelor
Edwards for thank you councelor Mrs
Fleming
four thank you councelor Fluker
against councel Harker
for councelor herd four thank you
councelor helm
oh he's not here apologies um councelor
Hall is not here councelor Jarvis four
thank
you councelor
Lagan four thank you councelor
Mae four thank you councelor councelor
[Applause]
Morris counselor
Morris four definitely four thank you
councelor nun four thank you councelor
shessy four thank you councelor Sidle
four thank you councelor skines four
thank you councelor stamp four councelor
stilts four thank you councelor
Swain
four
councelor Mrs
Thompson four thank you councelor Miss
White four thank you chairman the result
of that is 23 for one against and one
abstention thank you Tara thank you that
that that motion is carried um the
application has been refused for the
reasons um
outlined um therefore I move to agenda
item 13 business by reason of special
circumstances considered by the chairman
to be urgent I have none I therefore um
close um the
meeting uh and I thank the members
contributions this afternoon I draw the
meeting to close at um 5 to three thank
whatever that
translates uh as the meeting is now
closed members well